uh the standards and testing agency was
conduct these SAS test they test these
tests uh over many years they're testing
with children and they are assured that
it was the right test for the children
this year challenging of course because
it has to test a whole range of
abilities but I'll certainly be looking
at the test as I do every year when the
tests are available to the public
let's get more now from our
correspondent Molina vaselunovic hi
Melena so there have been a lot of well
there's been a lot of concerns should we
say about this recent reading exam
that's right there's been a flurry of
criticism for both parents who say their
children have been left in tears but
also teachers who say they in some cases
struggled to understand the questions
and that this English test in particular
was Harder They say than in previous
years and the union the National
Association of head teachers said that
they will take their concerns to
off-call the exams regulator as well as
the standard testing agency which
delivers these tests independently from
the Department of Education because they
say that the purpose of these
assessments aren't to be some sort of a
grueling right of passage but rather to
measure children's attainment by the end
of year six now the way that they are
devised they are six 45-minute tests
that test match and English and really
the purpose of them is to hold the
school accountable for the children's
progress and also to be able to compare
schools amongst each other now the
school's Minister did say that they do
have to be challenged changing and they
do have to Encompass quite a lot of
range of abilities in order to also
recognize the children who are exceeding
the average level of attainment but the
point of them he did acknowledge wasn't
to be too difficult and certainly what
the parents are saying and what the
unions are saying is the feedback from
school leaders is that the children have
been left quite demotivated and quite
dejected after taking these tests some
children at least and that's certainly
not the point of them at this point of
their education